this was the question we were halfway
through resolving last time
okay now what we've done was
immediately prior to this to remember we
had a
look at a whole bunch of those
differentiate this
hence integrate that type questions
remember so for instance
now what was this one from memory i
think it was if you differentiate
now there's an x log x in there
somewhere isn't it
x log x was it minus x isn't it yeah
okay
you do that and you get far out okay you
get the two in
being log x okay is it back
we made the statement that if you
integrate everything with respect to x
okay
this is what we got
okay so we use that to calculate this
area
okay however we didn't need to okay so
there's another approach we got halfway
um to explain yeah which is to say since
this is
log x right uh log
base e of x okay what we can do is
compare this to a function we know much
more about
a function we know is much easier to
integrate namely
e in the x so hopefully i think from
memory this is what we had
started to draw
there's standard old e to the x
okay now the question is thinking about
the area we were given
in the first place okay what area
does it correspond to on this graph
what does it correspond to now the first
thing you want to think about is the
fact that since we've done
we've taken the inverse function okay
your y's and x's
have switched around yes
so therefore the first thing you can say
is this one and this e which
used to be x values okay
what are they now they're on the y-axis
right you can see there's the one and
you go up a little further
two there'd be three so e and b just
so that's where your boundaries were
before okay i can shade in where my area
is now
if you want you could sort of turn your
head sideways
and you can see this is kind of like the
log function
flipped around so it's the same symmetry
yeah so this
is the area of my master okay
so i'm almost there how am i actually
going to calculate this area if this is
my setup
okay um we had a look at questions which
sort of challenges before
this area you can't form a nice the
integral form yeah
if we integrate with respect to x we're
not going to get this area what area
would we get
we'd get the area that's underneath the
curve
this dotty think here okay now even
though it's not the area what it's close
enough to the area
that i want that we can still use it
okay so let's just quickly fold down
okay
area under the curve
okay so what integral should we form
tell me
okay so the lower bound is zero
and the upper bound would be just one
wouldn't it
because x equals one so y equals e to
the power of one which is e
good it checks out okay so from naught
to one this is our
function and off go okay let's just
quickly evaluate it it's not hard
what's the primitive
zero to one okay so then go ahead and
e minus one happy
okay great so now that i've got the area
beneath the curve all i need to do
is compare it to the area that i
actually want so you've got that
rectangle there
right or this rectangle
what's the area of that whole rectangle
it's just
it's e units high one unit wine so the
area
of the rectangle
is e so therefore the shaded area
we can just do a subtraction it's the
rectangle
minus the area beneath the curve
which is what we expected to get from
the beginning
okay so which
which sorry what was i thinking which
approach would you use um
which bridge is quicker
it kind of depends doesn't it at the
moment
if you already know that this is true
then this is quicker
because you just have one integral you
just evaluate it it's easy to evaluate
you're fine
okay but by and large when you're not
expected to know what this is it's not a
standard integral
so more than likely i think i mentioned
this before part a would be this
then part b would be now you get the
area so actually you're doing the
working way
i think they're about the same um as for
which i default to i think i default
toward this
because i don't remember this you know
you might meet it enough times and
you'll be like oh it's making me
familiar
but this you know like the back of your
hand okay so that's kind of where i
default
either of mine